[Music]
have you ever dreamed of winning
millions of dollars what I'm starting to
figure out
today in my life is everyone's business
strategy is Lotto I need to make sure
that I'm making it clear to people I
think something happened the last 15
years that people don't realize how
impossible all these things are what you
just said was crazy and I think the
internet and all this weird [__] and
like Taylor Swift showing up at your
wedding like I think people see like a
highlight and think it's
real I day trade attention and build
businesses Legacy is greater than
currency what are we doing here Kish
what's What's the 411 one of the things
that we're doing today is breaks which
is a new feature this year where we can
through these digital pack breaks people
can jump in by fractions of packs
rip things and see what you pull first
step is you got to rip your starter pack
I just want to know who Gary is going to
lock in here for his first place yep I'm
going to go burrow based on
schedule Kish I love you continued
success with r makers good stuff shout
out good luck in week one all right
brother stay well bye everyone what
you're watching here is me sitting with
our leadership team and having a
conversation that is clarifying
principles processes strategies with the
the organization it is hard to get 2,000
people aligned on a mission so I do this
with a smaller group of leaders then we
will have another one in a week with 80
to 100 people and then within 2 or 3
weeks I will address all 2,000 people in
the company on the current things that
we think are misunderstood or not
effectively being executed in the Vayner
X or Vayner media
[Music]
World
ask one question an amazing lineup of
CEOs Founders and experts this is
marketing for the now how you doing Gary
I'm good yeah I missed marketing for now
so when you um think about the concept
of back to school what comes to mind
back to school is that time of year when
you're getting your kids ready for going
back in the fall and certainly for
college as well but I like to think
about it Gary also is a time where we as
adults can reflect and think a little
bit about our own learning when I was
growing up it was heard of for a
32-year-old human being to be thinking
about learning you'd hear like one sin
of Blue Moon somebody going to night
classes and almost always it was based
on the insecurity they had of not having
a certain degree whereas now the
progressive conversation rightfully so
is with the way the internet works
people now actually believe that they
can change their careers at 36 if they
allocate digital learning or maybe even
physical learning when you think about
Innovation and education and you think
about some of the challenges look I'm a
pretty public figure that's been fairly
loud I do not believe that College in
the way it's constructed is for everyone
in every scenario especially when you
take on an extraordinary amount of debt
and your natural skills or interest will
take you to a place where those classes
and that degree will not create the
outcome that you're looking for I think
a lot of times people think that I'm
anti-education when I say I don't
believe in college for everyone I'm
actually the reverse I'm so
uncomfortably Pro education I'm just Pro
self-awareness
and reality of one's situation not
Universal vanilla ideology one size fits
[Music]
all when you don't have unlimited money
or any money yes in 2023 September 7th
2023 and you are trying to sell [__] the
number one thing on earth is organic
social social media at scale cuz it's
[__] free or you're stuck in the spot
that you're in now which is you're
begging for a [__] miracle that
someone's going to give you cash if you
flipped it and just understood you're
100% in control [__] a competition [__]
a VC [__] everybody it was like an
Eminem like [__] a papa dot [__] a clock
[__] a trailer [__] everybody [__] a
papa do if you just understand that
you're fully in control and you just
have to pound social yeah and start
googling how to make the best Shopify
site selling T-shirts enter M literally
that [__] is out there for free best
practices get the proper Shopify get
your Social crazy how are you getting
back to Boston going taking fairies
later beautiful yeah you chop it up and
whatever happened New York but then you
have to like start dming people in
Boston in [__] Instagram # search top
posts click oh this person's here they
have 400,000 followers they're a cool
kid in high school and DM them be like I
want you wear my [__] shirt one in a
100 of them will my whole thing is like
you know how I got here by actually
doing what I'm telling you to do when
nobody in the world knew who the [__] I
was I stayed on Twitter in 2007 from
8:00 p.m. to 4: in the morning after I
worked the whole day in the liquor store
for [__] 4 years you have two choices
the luck of cash or sweat the problem is
1% of 1% hit the lottery ticket of it
happening fast the other 10% that make
it eat [__] for a decade but everyone's
fixated on the 1% of the 1% of the 1%
who hits something and even those people
quietly had to eat [__] for a little
while too I really
appreciate
it's now I'm ice looking at Ace watch my
sister since we last talked we're
looking to Target it into a kids product
right we really want to Target the
school system and it's kind of on brand
to what you were talking about earlier
marketing from the now right something
I'm fascinated with right now is
Partnerships US Foods Cisco people that
already prvy to these school systems in
New York City but basically what we're
trying to do is provide better food to
kids in the school system right like as
an African-American young Chef coming up
I grew up in public system right we had
[__] food I think the banana pudding
could be a gateway to that that's kind
of the lay work I also think a lot about
Magnolia Bakery even some type of
partnership there it's similar to the
kids that I met in bapson earlier I
think we're in a generation that don't
understand but I'm talking like every
entrepreneur on Earth getting a deal
with Cisco or getting a deal with
Magnolia bakeries is a one in a
47,000 thing so yes and you should then
go to the other 39 things that you can
think of and send them emails and
content and all that what I'm starting
to figure out today in my life is
everyone's business strategy is Lotto
getting into the school system through
Cisco is like [__] impossible I need
to make sure that I'm making it clear to
people people cuz I think people are
thinking smart like that smart thinking
I just have a pretty good feeling that
people don't realize how impossible all
these things are cuz when I grew up what
you just said was crazy and I think the
internet and all this weird [__] and
like Taylor Swift showing up at your
wedding like I think people see like a
highlight and think it's real so the
answer is yes but I want to make sure
that you don't make that your strategy
that you make that your this would be
some remarkable [__] maybe while I'm
over here doing this hello everybody
Welcome to September's wine of the month
club I am Gary vaynerchuk here with my
best friend Brandon War best friend what
do we have here first okay so we're
starting with a burgundy here this is
the uh Cecil Pak meon vage 2022 and the
bouquet on this wine ising amazing it's
crazy right but I was actually thinking
the same thing just before we on this is
bananas ironically bananas in it as well
I think coone continues to be a place
that is wildly
underrated wow tobacco chocolate violets
red flowers beef jerky talk about a wine
that I would have with a steak
immediately what did this score Brandon
uh 90 92 or 93 something like that you
know which is solid there are millions
of wines made most don't get 90 points
we spend 100% of our time trying to find
wines four people that are rated 90
points and higher at a good deal I know
it's why I'm so passionate about wine
text this was fun this was
engaging
next this is David Ritz the handsome
incredible tennis player me and him are
talking about flyfish Club we're also
talking about little Maven our new
restaurant that's actually opening up in
October in New York City getting into
the hospitality game with the BCR group
it's Prime Time and so you can probably
tell by the seriousness of this footage
these were like serious meetings really
going through numbers really going
through Ops like the real [__] again
kind of excited about in with the LV
behind the truth of the day today and I
hope you enjoy this you know 8:34 p.m.
still in office ROV and I just did a
bunch of stuff on the new book that I'm
really excited about I still got two
meetings with Sid who runs team Gary and
then I've got steel behind Sid 10 people
from bner sports are here because
tonight's Thursday of the NFL season
tonight's going to be an 11: p.m but you
sleep in the bed that you make you know
I tell people all the time like I'm inol
contr if I don't like it stop doing it
you are in control of your ambition and
so you need to live within it just
watching so many people complaining
about [__] that they decided to do I
can't cry about 11:00 p.m. I chose it
and if I start to get to a place where I
don't enjoy it for a sustained period of
time then I'll adjust cuz that's what
I've done my whole life you were in
control of the bed that you decide to
sleep in remember that if you could like
15c summary that thought letting the
lotto dictate the way you're your
business or your career yeah big theme
in today's episode like you literally
watched me today in the baps meeting
first and then the scholarship meeting
second get to the Epiphany in real time
that oh [__] people's entire strategy is
Lotto a lot of your strategies are based
on somebody El saying yes to a highly
unlikely request this is why I love
social media so much you can control the
demand coming to you by you going out
there and building the audience versus
trying to have someone give you Their
audience Lotto
face we got a phone inside the all the F
[__] that I seen it being real is kind
of rare I met with every label but I
ain't never sign a deal if we [__]
then we [__] I kiss your lips just
keep them still it was me and